[Music]
one of the things that makes boston
dynamics unique is its ability to create
dynamic stable leg machines of any size
shape or style these designs enable
their robots to brave nearly every
terrain and perform tasks in
environments too difficult
or inaccessible to people or other
machines its evolution since the
founding in 1992
has been mind blowing their first
prototype came out in 2004 called the
big dog
and their latest is handel a research
robot released in 2020.
their designs have even been recognized
in tv series and video games
like black mirror and heroes of the
storm proving
their insane popularity today we're
going to take a look at where they
started and how they went from this
to this welcome back to our channel if
you haven't already
make sure you hit the subscribe button
and ring the bell so you never
miss an upload from us first what is
boston dynamics we don't blame you if
you haven't heard of this company
if it was owned by elon musk we would
get almost daily if not
hourly updates on everything happening
with the company but the founder mark
rabert
is actually quite private and prefers to
work in silence
headquartered in waltham massachusetts
boston dynamics is an american robotics
design company
it was first owned by google and as of
by the hyundai motor group they are
known for their highly mobile robots
which combine principles of dynamic
control and balance with sophisticated
mechanical designs
and next generation software these
robots are equipped with navigation
perception and intelligence and what
sets them apart from other robotic labs
is the fact that all their designs have
legs
boston dynamics believes that mobility
in natural and man-made environments
requires legs the idea was to make a
robot that could go anywhere humans
could go
and even where humans couldn't go for
safety reasons after all
dangerous work doesn't just happen at
factories they happen out in the natural
world
here you need to navigate rocky terrain
staircases
doors and narrow paths if the
environment cannot change
obviously the machine must adapt they
have been working on perfecting the
design with each upgrade for the last
30 years first in theory and then
practically
before founding boston dynamics rayburt
was a professor of electrical
engineering at mit
and taught computer science and robotics
at carnegie mellon university
he built the first self-balancing
hopping robots in 1980 under his company
leg laboratory which was quite a huge
leap in robotics
from there he became passionate about
bipedal and quadrupedal robotics
it's easy enough to call what they do
artificial intelligence
but the robot's capabilities are better
described as athletic intelligence
they can walk climb stairs avoid
obstacles
and manage all kinds of terrain that
doesn't mean however
that they lack cognitive intelligence
they can root paths
autonomously for example if required
they can also respond to voice commands
of course getting to the point of
creating a humanoid robot that can do
backflips took a lot of work and
development
so let's take a look at the evolution of
the boston dynamic robots
the big dog 2004 the big dog was a
quadripetal robot
created with forster miller the jet
propulsion laboratory
and harvard university concord field
station
a lot of big names it was developed to
serve as a robotic mule
to accompany soldiers in terrains too
rough for jeeps and trucks
it was deemed the world's most ambitious
legged robot
and it was designed to carry 340 pounds
of baggage
alongside a soldier at four miles per
hour efficiently
navigating rough terrain at inclines of
up to 35 degrees
it is three feet long and stands two and
a half feet high
and it can stand up sit down walk with a
crawl or a trot
and run the big dog contains about 50
sensors
which measure altitude and acceleration
of the body motion
and force of joint actuators footage of
the new generation big dog
was released by boston dynamics showing
its ability to walk on ice
and recover balance when kicked from the
side unfortunately the project was
closed because the prototypes made too
much noise
and of course noise is the last thing
you need in that situation
little dog 2010 unlike big dog which is
run by boston dynamics
little dog is funded and operated by
darpa and it was created to help
progress in rough terrain locomotion
algorithms
it has four legs each powered by three
electrical motors
and a wide range of motion it is strong
enough to climb
and the on-board computer does the
sensing and communicating
little donk sensors measure joint angles
motor currents
body orientation and foot to ground
contact
it can run for 30 minutes without
needing a recharge
and wireless communications also allow
you to control the device remotely
cheetah 2012 true to its name the
cheetah is a four-legged robot that can
gallop at 28 miles per hour
which is the land speed record for
lagged robots this by the way
is faster than the fastest man in the
world usain bolt
his record speed is 27.8 miles per hour
and yes
that means there is no escaping this
robot cheetah even if you're an olympian
but this definitely isn't the final
version of the cheetah
keep in mind that this record is set in
an environment where there is no wind
resistance
and the treadmill doesn't make the robot
turn in different directions
so in theory if you were being chased by
a cheetah robot
you could simply take a step to the left
but the robot can climb steps
and even jump over obstacles while
running atlas
2016 this agile six foot tall bipedal
humanoid robot
is designed for various search and
rescue tasks and the fact that it looks
like something out of a marvel movie is
just an added bonus
in february 2016 boston dynamics
released a clip on youtube titled
atlas the next generation which showed
the robot performing all sorts of tasks
and in the follow-up in 2018 atlas could
literally do
parkour they followed it up with another
video titled more parkour in 2019
of course its capabilities go far beyond
tricks and dancing
atlas is equipped with two vision
systems a laser rangefinder and stereo
cameras
both of which can be controlled remotely
it has good motor skills and his limbs
can navigate rugged terrain and climb
using arms and legs it was made to help
in emergency services in search and
rescue missions
and do things like shutting off valves
opening doors
and operating machinery where humans
cannot go
unfortunately the department of defense
declared they didn't want to use robots
of offensive or defensive measures still
atlas performed several tasks and passed
all tests with
flying colors they included removing
debris from a blocked pathway
climbing an industrial ladder breaking
through a concrete panel
and connecting a firehouse to a
standpipe then turning on the valve
we can't tell why the dmd wouldn't want
such a handy robot around to relieve
pressure on the troops and
making things safer it would undoubtedly
be a big help
spot 2016. in the same year boston
dynamics was working on a four-legged
canine inspired robot called spot which
weighs only 55 pounds
they released a video in 2018 where spot
used its front claw to open a door
and the next month another video of spot
trying to open a door despite
interference from humans
spot helps in gathering data safely and
accurately from the remotest
most inaccessible places it can carry up
to 30 pounds of research equipment
and can be controlled remotely if you
want consistent data over the course of
weeks or months
spot can also go completely autonomous
and do
that for you it has 360 degree
perception to map terrains
avoid obstacles and mobility to cruise
over loose gravel grass
and stairs in 2018 rayburt announced on
techcrunch that spot was going into
pre-production
and preparing to roll out for commercial
availability
in november 2019 the massachusetts state
police force
became the first law enforcement agency
to use spot mini
as a robot cop as well as in the unit's
bomb squad
in fact spot has even been used by
spacex at their starship test site
to help contain sub-cooled liquid
nitrogen and to inspect potentially
dangerous
areas around the launch pad but it's not
all work and no play
in july 2020 a team of spot robots also
performed as cheerleaders
in the fukuoka softbank haws vs rakuten
eagles match
pick 2019 technically pick is not a
robot
it needs to be attached to a warehouse's
existing commercial robots
in a video published in 2019 we see pick
use a combination of vision sensors and
learning software
to palletize and depalletize boxes they
can identify
shapes and sizes of boxes move up to 720
boxes
in an hour and adapt to any type of
parcel whether rectangular
or irregularly shaped handle 2020
this is another robot with two flexible
legs on wheels and two hand-like
appendages to manipulate or carry
objects
you could think of it as more mobile
version of pick
it can stand over six feet tall travel
at nine miles per hour
and jump four feet high it is meant for
moving boxes and warehouses
it has a small footprint long reach and
a vision system to help unload trucks
and move boxes
basically it can operate entirely on its
own
it has a pick rate of 360 boxes per hour
and it can handle multiple jobs whether
that's getting a box from a high shelf
or transporting something to another
warehouse handle actually uses many of
the same dynamics
balance and mobile manipulation
principles found in other robots by
boston dynamics
but with only about 10 actuated joints
it is much
less complex all that said atlas
is definitely the superior robot it
forces the boston dynamics team to
advance the state-of-the-art software
and hardware designs
because it's so beautifully complex and
humans can identify with the humanoid
factor
it forces researchers to develop
techniques that deal with the freedom
atlas has
both in physical and cognitive
intelligence
though these robots are commercially
available there are some limits to
buying them
if you want a spot you can buy a maximum
of two on their website
and if you want more you'll have to
speak to the sales team
and if you were hoping to have some sort
of robot butler around the house
well these robots are very much for
industrial use
and can be handled only by people with
proper training
so definitely not for the home
especially if you have children running
around
but they are looking at customer facing
applications for future versions of the
robot
and it should be out in 2022 what do you
think of this evolution of boston
dynamics
let us know in the comments if you
enjoyed this video
be sure to hit the like button and check
out more videos like this on the simply
tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time